good morning everyone good day
um good evening Wherever You Are
um so the title of today's presentation
is Birds Oculus Hill applying
contrastive learning to fight and
isotropy in language models before we
start I want to give a little bit of a
background because because I'm sure we
have people from different cultures
um so
so Achilles is a person from from
ancient Greek mythology
he was a fighter a very successful one
he survived very he survived many very
difficult battles and was perceived as
someone super powerful and in vulnerable
this his story starts with with his
mother of his story of his
invulnerability starts with his mother
Ferris who dipped him in the sticks
River in order to make him hmm
vulnerable
so this thing happened but when he was
she was dipping him in the sticks River
she was still holding his uh his heel
and that was the only part of his body
that was not dipped in the river and
that was a part of his body that was
then injured and caused his his death
bird is a Transformer based large
language model and it's also known to be
very very powerful it's trained
pre-trained on web scale data in
self-supervised fashion so I'm like
logical data
and it has many many strong sides many
advantages it offers many advantages
but
the question for today is does it have
its Oculus heel as well
my name is Alexander molak I'm an
educator and speaker at lespire IO I'm a
machine learning engineering researcher
at iron scales I love problems
sharing slides currently
um I thought I am
ah so uh we are currently uh you're
currently not sharing slides but if you
uh
thank you so much for
um just uh
that's right that's an important one
does it work now it does work right now
yeah okay okay thank you great so I will
move back quickly so we talked about
Achilles we we talked about and talked
about his story and story of his mother
dipping him in the sticks River in order
to make him in vulnerable
and the in his heel that she was holding
him by his um by his heel I was the only
part of his body now that that remained
vulnerable and then became a cause of
his of his death and then we talked
about birth a large Transformer based
language model that is pre-trained on on
the huge Corpus Corpus of web scale data
in self-supervised fashion and this
model has been shown to be very powerful
um much more powerful than anything that
we that we knew before including
combining models and so on and today we
want to ask this question regarding
Birds Achilles heel does he have one and
is an isotropy this uh on the secret
term is it a good candidate for for
Achilles uh a hill for bird and if so
can we do something to make bird less
vulnerable
yeah so my name is Alexander molak I'm
an educator and speaker at lispire
machine learning engineer and research
at iron skills I love traveling with my
wife running I enjoy good vegan food and
I'm currently working on a book on
causality in Python so is that something
that's interesting to you you can scan
this QR code and learn more let's start
with a quick agenda
so we'll start with a quick refresher on
Transformer model and I'm sure that many
of you know this model how it works but
we'll do it anyway for those who might
need a refresher then we'll talk about
an isotropping what it is and why it
might be something bad in the context of
large language models then we'll talk
about contrastive learning
so we'll Define contrastive learning and
we'll also get some context why
contrastive learning might be relevant
when we're talking about Transformer
models and isotropy
and finally we'll talk about uh some
practical stuff so how to leverage
contrastive learning
in order to fight fight an isotropy and
how to build embeddings using
contrastive learning
in Python using a library called Sim CSE
and finally we hopefully will have some
time for for your questions
okay so Transformer model what is it
it's a
in its Essence it's it's a neural
network it's a pretty complex neural
network
that has certain properties so we'll
talk about two aspects of Transformers
today that will be relevant for us so
first the Transformer model is
pre-trained on a self-supervised task
which means that we do not provide this
model with any labels
we only provide the model with with the
training data unlabeled and then
we create an objective without adding
labels so we'll talk about this in more
detail in a second how precisely it
works and and second it uses
self-attention mechanism
okay
uh so this is a
an example task that can be used to
train transformer models and this is
called mask language model so what we do
here we just collect natural language
sentences for from whatever the sources
it can be Wikipedia it can be the whole
internet I don't know Reddit and so on
we pass them to the model and from time
to time we just mask one single word
and we ask model to predict this word
based on the context it has so for
instance here you have two sentences
with two different masks the first one
is this is a mask and
the second variation of the same
sentence also mask is mask is 80. so the
original sentence is this is a t
and we mask those random words from from
time to time in different in different
ordering and the second sentence is John
likes to serve and then in the first
iteration we mask the word serve and in
the second iteration we mask the word
likes
so that's the task and we'll talk about
certain properties of the embeddings
that we can achieve using this task in a
second but now let's talk about the
second aspect self-attention
so self-attention allows us to do
something very important it allows us to
measure relative importance of words and
the model measures this relative
relative importance automatically which
means this is a part of the training
objective
or to be precise this is a part of the
part of the
[Music]
it it measures it through through the
values of the parameters of the model so
we learn this relative importance during
the training jointly with all the other
parameters of the model and second thing
is that self-attention allows us to
model contextual meaning what does it
mean
um in linguistics we sometimes
um Talk About a Thing Called polysemy
which means that we can have the same
term that has two different meanings
okay so one example that I could give
you is
you can say hey yesterday I went to the
bank to pick up my new credit card
okay and another sentence you can say is
I spent a lovely evening on the Wind on
the riverbank okay so we have word Bank
in both those sentences but the meaning
of those words is completely is
completely different
in the first sentence we talk about Bank
as a building or an institution and in
the second uh
as a river as a riverbank
um now why this is important this is uh
this example gives you like a very
pronounced difference between those two
meanings but sometimes the differences
in the meaning for the same word might
be much more subtle but still they might
influence the way
um
the way we predict and answer whatever
the answer is
so those models are thanks to
self-attention mechanism those models
are able to model this
so here you have a visualization of
self-attention
Weights in one of the early one of the
early layers of of the birth model so
what are attention weights is a this is
a type of coefficient that says how
relevant another word
is to the current word that we are
looking at so you can see that maybe if
we say there then
we have the strongest attention weight
to cat so it looks once one step one
step ahead and says like there what what
is the object it's the cat and then from
CAD it has one attention way to the CLS
talk and it's a technical thing
um but also another attention way pretty
strong is to set so cat set so cat what
was cat doing it's sad right
um
so this is how it works and we can also
see that this changes through the layers
so we can see in this animation
that attention weights are different in
each layer so in each layer model learns
something something new about the
connection between different words and
how they and how they build meaning
and one very important thing about the
representations that we can obtain using
models like Transformers but also
earlier models like where to vac is that
we
map words to a continuous space so words
are discrete right the cat is just one
word there's no continuous way between
cat and dog in the in in the language
you can say half cat half dog of course
something like this but language is
discrete in its nature
so what we're doing we are uh what we're
doing quick models like like
Transformers We Are mapping words to a
continuous space and we can perform
certain operations in this space
um and there are a couple Key properties
of this space so first of all words that
have similar meaning tend to group
together okay so words that are that
have similar meanings should be should
be mapped to points that are close to
close in the close to each other in the
embedding space so we have train bus and
taxi we can see that they're very close
but cat and dog are much further from
bus and Taxi
and yoga and pillar and pilates are kind
of far away from King but close to each
other and so on and so on
and so this is the this is the ideal
scenario and
many researchers showed that models like
word to vague and all the later models
they have this property
uh but then
all the researchers demonstrated that
this property is not always there or not
always to the extent that we that we
wish to
so now let's talk about anisotropping
okay this word might sound scary to you
and that's I think that's natural
also it's not a skirt to me scary to me
when I'm ready for the first time so
let's uh let's take uh let's take a
smaller part of this world and let's
talk talk about isotropy so isotropy is
a is a word that is derived from ancient
Greek from two Greek words
ethos and protos and esos means equal
and protos means way Direction
so isotropy means equal in each
Direction in a sense
being a little bit more formal we could
say that it's uniform in every direction
and mapping this intuition to to
something statistical we can talk about
isotropic gaussian distribution so
isotropic distribution is is a
distribution
where we go in every direction in a
sense the same way so here we will limit
ourselves we'll limit this definition of
isotropy to to a spherical gaussian
although this is not entirely not true
so we can see that here we have two
variables X and Y and the spread for X
and Y
is like the same in every direction in a
sense okay
if we map it to three dimensions we have
a sphere okay so the circle gets into a
into the shape of a three-dimensional
sphere so we have now three variables
and they have the same properties
and technically speaking an isotropic
distribution isotropic gaussian is a
distribution that has covariance Matrix
in a form of
uh variance time identity Matrix but
this is not very important to us
but non-isotropic
non-isotropic
distribution will have spread that is
that is not equal in every in in every
sign and I'm talking about equal spread
although technically it's not not
necessarily correct because the methods
that we will discuss in a second
will will try to build distributions
that are isotropic
but I also limited to a unit sphere okay
so that's why we focusing on on
spherical on spherical distributions
multivariate spherical distributions
so we know that isotropic distribution
can look like this for instance and
anisotropic might look like this
and now let's look let's see what
happens in in reality so this is a
distribution of embeddings for for a
model called Roberta another
Transformer based model
and as you can see these embeddings they
form a type of a cone they're like has
like a narrow narrow tape tip when where
we have a large concentration of many
many different embeddings
so each embedding here might be each
point my my represent either a word or a
document right
and and
when we um when we when we do certain
transformations to this embeddings we
can get much closer to something more
spherical and something more isotropic
so this comes from a paper by by Lua
from 2021 and here they used white link
this is one of the like let's say
transformations
um but now let's think about it what is
the cost of of getting this uh this this
tip so so dense here so this narrow cone
might cause
that the similar object might get a
little bit too close to each other so
for instance when he talked about train
and a cat
in this cone train and a cat might be
pretty close to each other maybe not as
close as cat and dog but but but pretty
close
now
one challenge with this is that if we
have this it might be very difficult to
build a decision boundary so a model
will need to build a decision boundary
that is very curvy and goes between all
those cats and dogs to separate them to
separate them from trains and buses
right because there's very little space
and when when the representation is
isotropic then our decision boundary
essentially becomes linear okay which
means that it will become a hyper plane
in high dimensional space
okay so let's talk about contrastive
learning now
so what is contrastive learning
contrastive learning is a type of
training
for for neural networks so machine
learning models in in in in broader
sense where we use
similar examples and this similar
examples in order to make
representations of similar objects
closer to each other
and
make representations for this similar
object
far further away from each other
so here we can see we have like a cat
and a cat so that could be a so-called
positive pair for contrastive learning
so we say positive pair means that these
objects are similar we pass them to the
network and the network learns that
their representation should be close to
each other and then we have a cat like
this kitten and and a puppy and we say
that they are not similar to each other
we say this is a negative person called
a negative pair
so how do we do it uh if we don't know
what what is what is in the pictures or
in the sentences right I'm using
pictures here because I think they are
more intuitive but the same we can do
for for words and four sentences
uh so that's a very good question uh
because maybe we need the model to label
those those pictures but the answer is
much simpler you know so we can actually
take one picture
and perform two different augmentations
of this um of this picture and use those
augmentations as as positive Pairs and
then take a picture and another picture
and use them as negative pairs
of course this might this might
Inspire to ask another question hey but
what if we take another picture and it's
a it's a cat as well right and it's a
very good question well this will
introduce Some Noise to the model
now it seems in practice that this noise
is actually not making the model
to fail and maybe it also it is also
advantages in the sense that it brings a
little bit of regularization
to the model so this looks like this and
this is a another architecture called
same Clear for for images
you can see that you encode those two
pictures using two uh using two
different networks and then you maximize
agreement for uh for similar pairs and
um and push the negative purse further
away from each other
so but we are talking about language so
uh so so that will be slightly different
but only slightly we'll talk about this
paper you can scan this QR code if you
if you're interested in uh in learning
more it's called same CSC simple
contrastive learning of sentence
embeddings
so how can we do it for language there
are two ways proposed in this paper the
first one is unsupervised the second one
is supervised
and we will focus on the unsupervised
one uh today but supervised is very very
similar in its essence
and for for unsupervised we essentially
use the same sentence
and then for natural language for
natural language it's it's much more
difficult
to augment the data in in a meaningful
way right we can change some words we
can do all those leaves we can put
random words that's what people are
trying to do sometimes but it not always
it doesn't always uh work very well and
sometimes it can distort the meaning in
um
very seriously especially when we have
short sentences so what the offers uh
done have done here is very interesting
because they leveraged the Dropout mask
in Transformer architecture
to do augmentation for them so they
embed the same sentence twice without uh
freezing the seed for for Dropout masks
so Dropout masks are slightly different
for both
um for both embeddings and then we have
slightly different representations and
they are treated as a similar or
positive pair and then we take one
sentence in another sentence as a
negative pair and this tends to work
pretty well for supervised learning what
people do is they usually use
data sets like snli and so on
okay so how anisotropy and contrastive
learning are connected
it turns out that we can uh we can talk
we can find um
two different uh ways of expressing
features related to anisotropy under
alignment and uniformity so uniformity
means that representations of our images
or words or sentences as in our case are
distributed on the hypersphere uniformly
okay and this allows us to preserve
maximal information
and this also allows us to build
decision boundaries that are very simple
so we can basically use hyperplanes in
the idealized case
and the second one is alignment or the
first one is alignment which means
um that similar objects are mapped to
similar to points that are close to get
to to each other in the space so when we
optimize for those two uh for those two
properties it turns out that we are
actually moving towards and towards an
isotropic
um
dollars and isotropic representation
and and so by as authors has shown by
using contrastive learning objective we
can do this mapping from this narrow
cone to this more spherical shape here
and thanks to this we are also getting
good alignment and good uniformity
and how does it work uh there are here
are a couple of different
models uh so there is expert which
stands for sentence bird with whitening
uh we have different other
Transformations like bird flow expert
flow and so on and here we have SimCity
and on x-axis and y-axis we have lost
the align
the alignment loss term and here we have
uniform uniformity loss term on X so
this means that the closer the point is
to to do
the left
bottom corner the better so you can see
that
for uniformity maybe expert with
whitening is slightly better but it's
much worse in terms of alignment so same
CSC especially the supervised one
is getting getting us much better
balance between alignment and uniformity
and in this sense it gives us much more
isotropic
representation if you're interested in
understanding more about this you can
check this article this is our review
that we wrote with Mike earlyson
uh regarding contrastive learning and in
the meanwhile let's see how all of this
works in Python
so this is a repository that you can
scan and you can follow there are two
notebooks there
I will give you a couple of seconds to
scan it if you want
okay and now let's do it so
so this is pretty easy we can just use
sim CSC Library import Sim CSC object
from this Library
foreign
I won't do it because it takes a lot of
time and then
we just encode any sentence any phrase
even a single word
by using the encode method on the model
it takes a while usually but not very
long
and then what we can do we can we can
encode many sentences and just embed
them in this space and do perform
classification on this on top of this
and or any other task we can use it for
any other tasks and these embeddings
will have better properties than regular
bird on or Roberta
foreign so another thing we can also
compute similarities
so here we have some sentence attending
pilata Global is awesome and another one
Jenny is hungry sad face
and another pair of sentences is
attending by data Global is awesome and
python conferences are great
so we expect that the similarity for the
second pair of sentences will be higher
than for the first one
and it's true so for the first one
similarity is point one four and for the
second one point